[Applause]
[Music]
have you heard about this thing called
mass effect Rex schreber Rex shiver it's
some space game all the kids are talking
about I don't know but if you want to be
the first to know about all the new
games make sure to hit that subscribe
button now let's get to it it's been
over five years since we took a journey
with mass effect and now Andromeda is
here to take us to a whole new galaxy
this time around the Pathfinders are on
a mission to find a new planet that can
sustain human life all the while
contending with the evil ket new planets
alien races and quests fill the
Andromeda galaxy and you'll be able to
start exploring on ps4 xbox one and pc
on Tuesday March 21st in the US Thursday
March 23rd in the UK if you're in the
mood for more space stuff right now you
can check out our two-part mini
documentary on Andromeda the story of
mass effect speaking of other planets
let's take a peek at the Japanese
fantasy world of toukiden to the third
game in the series puts you in control
of a slayer who finds himself teleported
to a mysterious village with no memory
what follows is an open world adventure
full of monsters of all shapes and sizes
the new demon and ability can help you
take them down and you can even raise
companion animals to help you on your
journey toukiden two dropped in Japan
last year but the game comes stateside
for ps4 PS Vita and PC on march 21st and
that's not the only game featuring giant
monsters this week troll and I stars a
young boy named Otto and his giant troll
friend the pair will have to work
together to escape a hunter who's
tracking them across post-world war two
scandinavia auto and the troll both have
their own set of abilities but they'll
have to combine forces to solve puzzles
and get by you can also team up with a
friend to take on the challenge via
split screen troll and I comes to ps4
xbox one and pc on the 21st and an
and hosts which version is planned for
later this year have you played any
sports with your Mushroom Kingdom pals
in a while well Mario sports superstars
packages baseball golf soccer tennis and
horseback riding on to one handy
portable cartridge and these aren't just
little mini games either each sport has
its own tournaments local multiplayer
and online multiplayer to dig into think
of it as a way to get your hands on all
the Mario sports games of the past plus
some all-new horseback racing you can
kick things off on 3ds on March 24th if
you've never played a zero escape game
then the notary games are a perfect
place to start this two and one combines
remastered versions of nine hours nine
persons nine doors and virtues last
reward whether you like your video games
full of deep stories with philosophical
discussion or a ton of dense tricky
puzzles the nunnery games has something
for you and it doesn't hurt that you can
unlock special endings by going back to
earlier puzzles with the knowledge
you've gained from later in the game the
nunnery games comes to ps4 PS Vita and
PC on the 24th and those are the big
games will be playing this week as
always remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
guys and I'll be back with more next
week
you